Dave Ward is there is the General
Secretary of the communication Workers
Union uh hello again to you Dave yeah hi
again uh we spoke just a few weeks ago
didn't we on breakfast
um what's changed if anything since then
Dave
well what hasn't changed uh is the
spirit and Defiance of our members
against Royal mail's plans to start up
to three hours later in the day and to
basically bring in a different Workforce
based on self-employed workers uh agency
workers
replacing a new entrance on Lower terms
and conditions these guys are in
incredible spirit
um they are definitely in this for as
long as it takes because we do want to
reach a settlement there was some uh
positive more positive discussions uh on
Wednesday of this week the union
actually offered the company the
opportunity to suspend these two strikes
uh all we asked was that the company
confirmed uh that they wouldn't impose
unagreed change whilst we continue to
talk uh we asked them to confirm that
they wouldn't introduce a new resourcing
model which I spoke about earlier on uh
we also asked them to confirm that the
nine percent pay over 18 months which
they keep saying is on the table was
actually confirmed in writing they
couldn't do any of those things so
unfortunately we don't want to be in
this position our members you know love
uh delivering to their customers but
that's at stake as well because this
really is a fight over the very future
of Royal Mail deliveries to 32 million
addresses and businesses across the UK
you say you've had positive discussions
this week
what would you accept
compromise for these future strikes to
be canceled
well I want to be absolutely clear and I
have been every time we do an interview
we have set a role now on pay if it's
nine percent over 18 months which they
keep saying it is it's worth nine
percent if it was a real nine percent
where the full value of that nine
percent is back dated uh and is paid to
our members and it it can be linked to
change we haven't got a problem with
that
um then you know we'll settle the pay
aspect to this uh what the real sort of
major issues are as well as uh them
confirming the pay situation is that we
need to see this company they have moved
to a better position on no compulsory
redundancies but to make that come to
life the company needs to confirm that
they're not going to bring in a
different Workforce you can't have both
uh you know the existing Workforce and
plans to bring in agency workers in huge
numbers unlimited numbers of
self-employed workers who would have to
pay for the use of the vines and we want
to see a service for the public we want
to see Royal Mail competing on their
strengths of delivering to 32 million
addresses not abandoned in that service
now they're all big issues there's other
issues around flexibility where the
company wants to almost monitor our
people on a minute-by-minute basis and
not give them any certainty around what
time they're going to finish their their
daily delivery so there's lots of issues
here but you know we did make a bit of
progress and the union wants to continue
that and we'll offer a period of calm
again uh in January to try and finalize
an agreement but what they'll never do
they won't break the result of our
members because our members are in this
not just for their own jobs but also for
the customers that they love to serve
now you only need to look at the
headlines Dave to see just how Bleak
things are for so many people this
Christmas with travel disruption as they
try to get home or to wherever they're
going trying to make ends meet with the
cost of living crisis and not even able
to get things sent uh reliably by Royal
Mail it's impacted a lot of businesses
as well trying to get through this
Christmas period what would be your
message to them well our message to
people who are really finding it
difficult with these postal strikes is
that I think they know when they talk to
postal workers up and down the country
and our members do have a special
relationship with their customers I
think they know that our members are
actually trying to defend the services
and genuinely if we don't get a
settlement in this dispute uh that is is
properly in the interest of customers as
well you know Royal mail's proposals to
turn this great company uh into just
another parcel Courier on an asset strip
in leveling down agenda will destroy the
services that they've enjoyed uh not
just this Christmas but forever
and obviously there's been
there's plenty of uh supported uh your
members in this industrial action have
you had any uh reassurance from labor
that they would be able to offer you
anything different from what's currently
on the table from the government
um well look the government uh don't
directly uh deal with us in negotiations
because we're a private company now
where the government have a role and
labor have a role uh in this particular
dispute is to continue to promise to
deliver the the universal service which
is a public service that our members
deliver to every single household across
the UK wherever however remote that is
you know our ever busier town or city
that is we're out there delivering every
single day and that's the government's
part is what we're concerned about with
that is that Royal Mail are going behind
the backs of the public and going to the
government to try and get the government
to down dial those services and this is
all par all it's about is Royal Mail not
being interested into delivering and
competing with with the competitors on
their natural Advantage which is the
infrastructure through the company and
these great postal workers who have this
relationship on the doorstep with
businesses and households right across
the UK they should be seeing this as an
opportunity to innovate change needs to
be about improving services not cutting
back and services